let's say we want to figure out what 473
divided by
5 is
and like always why don't you pause this
video and try to work through it and if
you're familiar with the idea of
division with partial quotients i
encourage you to try it out that way
all right now let's work on this
together and so let me just rewrite this
in a format that makes it a little bit
easier for me to do my division with
partial quotients
and so i'm just going to write 473
divided by
5
and what's neat about division with
partial quotients is that there's a lot
of flexibility in how you do it there's
no exactly one right way and so you
could say all right how many times can 5
go into 473 without going over 473 you
might be tempted someone might say oh
maybe you can go 100 times but you could
quickly see that if you said 100 times
and you say how much do i have left over
you do 100 times 5 you'd get 500 and
you'd say oh wait wait i overshot 473.
so 100 is too high so then you would
back up a little bit and then you could
say all right i'm gonna i'm gonna go for
low numbers and just slowly chip away at
it so you might say that 5 goes into 473
you know it goes more than 20 times so
let's just start with 20.
well what is 20 times 5
20 times 5 is 100 and let me be very
clear what that is that is 20
times
our 5 right over there and so clearly we
did not overshoot it but how much how
many more times can 5 go into 473 then
20. to figure that out we figure out how
much more we have left over to go so we
subtract the 100 from 473
and we have 373.
so how many times can 5 go into 373
well
if 20 times 5 was 100
well gee this is 300 here so maybe we
can go another 60 times so let me put a
60 right over there and so what is 60
times 5
well 6 tens times 5 would be 30 tens
which is 300
and so how much further do we have to go
so we still have
73 left 373 minus 300 is 73.
so how many times does 5 go into 73
well let's see
i know 5 times 12 is 60. so let me try
12. so i will put a 12 over here and so
12 times 5 is 60 so how much further do
we have to go
let's see 73 minus 60 is 13
and 5 can go into 13 so we can get a few
more fives in there just to be clear
what we're doing we've already said hey
we can go 20 times and then another 60
and then another 12 times and if we go
into 473 all of those times we still
have 13 left over so we could go into we
can even fit a few more fives in there
now how many times does 5 go into 13
well 5 times 2 is 10 5 times 3 would be
too much so we could say 2 times
so that gets us 2 times 5 is 10
and so there what we have left over is a
3 and then we can't fit any more 5's in
we can't divide 5 into 3 so that's going
to give us our remainder so how many
times does 5 go into 473
well we were able to get it in there 20
times and then another 60 times and then
another 12 times and then another two
times so what we can do is we can add
all of these together and what do we get
2 plus 12 is 14 plus 60 is 74
plus 20 is 94
and then we have a remainder of 3 so
this is equal to 94
and then i'll write this in red with a
remainder of 3 did i do that right 2
plus 14 let's see 2 plus 12 is 14
74 yep 94. now let me just show you that
there's more than one way to do this and
i'll draw a little line here so we don't
get it too confused
we could have done something like this
we could have said what is 473
divided by
5
and we might have immediately recognized
that
all right 5 goes into 48 times so 5
would go into
480 times at least probably more times
than that but let's just start with 80.
and so how close does that get us to 473
well to figure that out we multiply 80
times 5 to get
400 and so can we fit any more fives
into the difference so let's figure out
the difference so we will subtract and
just to be very clear this was 80
times five the reason why we did that is
see how how close did we get to 473 and
now we want to figure out how much do we
have left over how many more fives can
we fit in and so you subtract 400 from
473 and we are going to get 73.
well we can for sure fit more fives into
73 we might say hey maybe let's try to
fit another 10 fives in there so let's
stick another 10 fives in there now how
close are we well 10 times 5 is 50 and
to be clear what we just did here is we
multiplied 10
times 5
and now can we fit any more 5's in well
to figure that out we would need to
subtract and figure out what what we
have left so 73 minus 50 that's going to
be
23 and we can for sure fit more 5's into
23 we know that 5 times 4 is equal to 20
so let's put four more fives in there so
four times five is going to be 20 let's
see how close we are now and to be very
clear that is four
times r5
and so what do we get to what do we have
left and can we fit any more 5's in
let's see 23 minus 20 is just 3
and that's less than 5 so we can't fit
any more 5's in so there we have it we
were able to get 85s into 473 we saw
that we still had some left over we were
able to fit another 10 into that
leftover and then we still saw that we
had some left over and we were able to
fit another 4 into that leftover and
then we had a leftover of 3 and we
weren't able to fit any more 5's in and
so in total we were able to fit
94
fives into 473 and then we had three
left over which is exactly what we had
there